my name is Dina heridos to Matisse and
I'm director of Carnegie Mellon's
information networking Institute and as
you may know but if you don't know the
eye and eye or the information
networking Institute is celebrating its
20th anniversary this weekend during
carnival and I want to give you a brief
overview of what I ni is I and I is a
department in the College of Engineering
that offers graduate programs and
information networking and security in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania bicoastal
programs with Silicon Valley and
programs around the world in kobe japan
lisbon and novato portugal and Athens
Greece I and I was established 20 years
ago pretty much triggered by the demand
from industry and our moderator today
Marvin see ruble will give us some
background information or tell the story
about how I and I was founded but from
the beginning I and I was established as
an interdisciplinary field of study that
would draw in the fields of electrical
and computer engineering computer
science public policy and business
management a blend of expertise that is
still valued by employers today today
the ini presents two panel discussions
on mobile communications and Internet
Security the first panel will be
presented now will emphasize the
evolution of telecommunications to
mobility and will be moderated by
professors Marvin sear boo who is the
founder of I and I the second panel
which starts at three forty-five in this
same room we'll focus on the work in the
areas of security and privacy and will
be moderated by pradeep k khosla who is
the Dean of the College of Engineering
the founder of Scilab and former
director of the eye and eye and I'd like
to begin now by introducing our first
panel along with our moderator and then
ask the panelists to introduce
themselves so the panel's titled
introduction I'm sorry it's called
evolution from telecommunications to
mobility learn how a 1980s partnership
with the telephone
he grew into a launchpad for the Scilab
mobility Research Center and other
emerging technology initiatives Marvin
cebu again who I mentioned was the
founder of ionized a professor of
engineering and public policy industrial
administration and electrical and
computer engineering he's been at
Carnegie Mellon University since 1985
and in 1989 he was the person who led
the founding of I and I he wrote the
proposal to bellcore and I'll let you
tell the story Marvin because you tell
it so well so let me hand it off to you
thank you okay you have to visualize
what the world was like in 1989 we had a
telecommunications industry it used to
be dominated by a ma bells but it just
my Bella had just broken up into AT&T
and seven regional Bell operating
companies but that industry was
completely separate from the computer
industry the software industry dominated
by companies like IBM and Digital
Equipment Corporation and their the
notion that there was something that
like distributed systems where you
actually had to understand both
communications and software was a
remarkably novel idea it was
sufficiently novel that bellecour
complained that it couldn't hire any any
people who knew both of those things and
so they wrote to a number of
universities and said would somebody
please create a program that combines
software and communications I probably
should have some business so that people
actually know what to invent rather than
just the technology and if you create
such program will send a lot of our new
hires to it because we need people who
are trained in those fields so with some
financial help from belk or to get
started and a slew students that they
finance to come in the early years we
began the ini with its master's program
in information networking that combines
precisely those fields and the program
has has continued to evolve over the
years of Bell Korres long since
disappeared as an entity swallowed up by
telcordia and then
saic but the idea of of computers and
communications being important remember
1989 is before the invention of the
World Wide Web it's tcp/ip was a
plaything of a few academic universities
no businesses used it for anything and
all of the things that we take for
granted today information on the web
electronic commerce and so on were all
still to be invented in many cases by
graduates of the early on I programs so
we're still here and still trying to
invent the future wherever that is going
to take us but built on the technologies
of communications distributed systems
software and business and we'll hear
some of that evolution in the activities
of students over the years from our
panel so without further ado I'm going
to begin and ask Jesse Schell to lead
off jesse is a graduate of the class of
nineteen ninety-four is it would have
been 93 93 90 93 the the fourth class of
the ini and is after going off and
working in industry has come back to CMU
as a faculty member right yeah so I was
one of those guys that's at Belcourt as
a matter of fact mm-hmm the what
happened to me is I'd been at Rensselaer
studying artificial intelligence and I
had a dream of having someone send me to
graduate school and so every every job i
applied for i said and who wants to send
me to graduate school to study
artificial intelligence and they all
said no no that's crazy that's not going
to happen except for bellecour who said
well we used to do that a lot but now we
only do it for computer networking and I
thought computer networking wants to do
that nobody wants to do that that's
boring and this remember this in 1992
before there was the web and that kind
of thing and I to go and think about it
and I remember going away and thinking
when I would go to think about things I
like to play pinball and I remember
playing this pinball game and thinking
do I really want to do this
computer networking it's not really what
I meant to well you know what I'd really
like to do build stuff like this pinball
machine yeah that'd be really cool now
how would I do that I thought as I SAT
there playing pinball well let's see
there's all these sensors and then they
collect data and they communicate to
each other over wires oh damn it is
computer networking and so that was how
I decided I'd go to the I&O anyway since
then I've done a few different things
I've I was at Disney's a virtual reality
studio I was a creative director there I
since came back to Pittsburgh in 2002
started teaching at the entertainment
Technology Center where i teach game
design and I opened a video game studio
here in town called shell games so I
think little Priya are trying our second
panelist is going to be Priya not worth
narasimha hon I could never pronounce it
properly apologize we just call it pre
around here who's an associate professor
in electrical and computer engineering
and director sigh labs mobility Research
Center sure hi I'm Priya and my
background is i was born in india raised
in africa in zambia specifically then i
went to Santa Barbara UC Santa Barbara
for my PhD I came to Pittsburgh and
until then I'd never seen a football
game or a hockey game in my life they
know about the sport didn't care about
either came here fell hard for both
sports so a lot of my research revolves
around sports technology and I hope I'm
going to get to talk to you about that
in a bit okay I third speaker is going
to be marshall knight who was a graduate
1996 from the ini and currently at AT&T
good afternoon i'm a rachel night and
I'm as Marva indicate I'm currently with
AT&T and I'm actually one of the
recipients of the scholarship when
bellcore and other regional Bell
operating companies were sending
students here and employees here to
honor and it was a very rewarding
expense for me it has allowed me to
evolve as
we're going to talk about the evolution
of telecommunications AT&T as a company
has evolved and with that has my career
and I've been a part of 80 for almost 15
years jewel for sale and celebrating 15
years of service with what's now 80
started out at Southwestern Bell
actually but I think I'd I really help
to shape my career we'll talk about some
of the things that have happened i'm
currently supporting our wireless in
entity and do an engineering program
management and so i look forward to
talking to you more and finally a seems
my logic who is with the professor is a
research professor in electrical and
computer engineering and at the
institute for complex engineered systems
and director of the laboratory for
interactive real-time computing systems
thanks very much Megan it's a great
pleasure to be on this panel and i will
be talking later about some of the
research projects that I&I students
participating participated working with
me that shaped i can say the history of
and future hopefully will be shaping the
self of mobile computing and provides
some pretty strong arguments behind that
namely i have had been working with I&I
students for over 15 years and some of
new areas and concept in mobile
computing have started here at carnegie
mellon part of that was I&I as well like
wearable computing context-aware
computing pervasive computing we did
first projects on all of these areas in
computing that you are now pretty much
used to hear but probably didn't know
about this and i will tell you also
about the projects that have research
agenda for another 10 years in the area
of mobile computing wait so the star
panel and we'll ask each of them
to say a few words now that we've
introduced them and we'll get we'll
start with Jesse I'm just saying a few
words no I mean tell us that this is
your opportunity we've done we have
about 10 minutes for each panelists all
right you're on all right and his
special I should talk about well as i as
i said earlier talk about the evolution
of the kinds of things that maybe you
did when you were here in in 93 and all
kinds of things that people are doing
now and okay will be interesting yeah
sure it's really interesting to look
back at how the world has changed since
I was an ini student again yeah i
remember it was pre-web being thinking
about what being at the ini pre-web is
very strange in fact i will never forget
the day I've been to die and I i don't
know maybe year or something and one day
Marvin says hey hey come over here check
this out and I'm like what is it he says
it's this thing called mosaic look look
and here it is is the first time I ever
saw a web browser was down there at
hamburg hall and you're like what was so
what is it you're like well there's a
lot of physics papers and and mostly i
don't know at that time was just physics
papers weather data in pornography
though there wasn't there right Lamar
was like I think this is really going to
go somewhere and sometimes how he was he
was right it was right about that anyway
so things that things have changed an
awful lot but for me the way I so we
would have just having discussions this
morning about the I&I and how it's
changed over the years and it's
interesting to me a lot of ways how much
it it hasn't changed about what a how
some of the students get on board with
very very with research projects that
are already kind of taking off and then
some people start on new ones and how
much it matters what came before and I
got involved in virtual reality it was
really this was the ini was my
introduction to virtual reality which
has ended up setting kind of the whole
whole pathway for my career because one
team of students the year before
done in experimental virtual reality
thesis and I just thought that sounded
really cool so I just started digging
around trying to find out how did they
do it who do they work with did they
want to be follow-up work and was a was
presser La Fleur over at the fine art
school who was who was you know I went
to him and I said hey you know you're
doing this virtual reality stuff you
know what are you doing he's as well
we're doing the virtual reality art
museum I said Wow what does that mean he
says I don't know I said well do you
need network programmers he says yes I
think so he said yeah because I've told
people we're going to do and exhibit
where we simultaneously are exhibiting
we're going to have a connected exhibit
where one one of those in Japan and the
other ones in Germany at the same time I
think I'm going to need some networking
guys for that I said oh okay all right
so well so we'll try and figure it out
and yeah from there I ended up going
back to bellecour and it was one of the
things just really interesting just
about the continuity the program so that
the program was really the eye and eye
as i understand it was initiated by i
never remember the guys name it was on
doors yes right and he was a VP at at
belk or and he his as you've mentioned
his big frustration at belk or was he
said we have three kinds of people here
we have electrical engineers computer
scientists in MBAs and none of them
could talk to each other we need some
people who were can bridge the gaps and
he got this thing going and then he
retired and so you know we when we all
got back we kept trapped there were 36
of us got back to bellecour there were
no strings attached for us when we
return so here we got free ride to
graduate school no strings attached when
we returned one of us left to each month
um I was I was the 18th to leave and I
left after a year and a half so I was a
I was I was right on right on schedule
with that because the company didn't
understand and appreciate what they had
they had these people who'd come and had
this study but they were not it wasn't
appreciated they weren't put in where
they were because unfortunately there
was
there wasn't follow through however I
mean the it's certainly the program's
credit how much has continued to sort of
grow and and thrive anyway I was
recently speaking to ionize students
because there is so there there is not a
lot of understanding I think in the
academic world about the importance of
computer networking when it comes to the
modern video game experiences the the
game experience is now are becoming
there they're almost all networked
they're almost all networked in novel
and unusual ways where you have
situations where so many people are
connected and people often think of
games is trivial but you look at a game
like farmville where you have 90 million
players who are all interacting and
that's often much larger than your
typical of network simulation and so one
of the things I'm kind of working with
the ini little bit is to kind of help
people understand this better because we
have this weird situation where the
computer gaming industry is just dying
to get talented Network programmers in
but network programmers don't seem very
interested in the game industries they
don't see it as a viable pathway for
some reason so there's a disconnect
there but it's it's it's I've just had a
fascinating time working with the
virtual reality stuff working with
massively multiplayer gaming and now
getting into the air the arenas of
social gaming and the things that are
happening with mobile it's it's just a
it's very exciting time because
everything's getting reinvented well
it's interesting that you say that
because gaming has been a driving factor
in computer science for 30 years when
the very first visual display computers
came out the alto from Xerox PARC they
you could play a distributed version of
asteroid game on it right and the
computer science department at the time
actually thought it was in the farias
plot to to suck up all the time of
everybody so that they wouldn't be as
productive and competitive with rocks
park mike my grandfather was actually a
programmer on e niak back in 1948
and I believe he may have created the
first computer game he was helped remove
it because they moved it from University
of Pennsylvania to the Pentagon and he
was responsible for helping to get it
put back together and testing it and
some of the test programs who wrote were
games and so it's funny it is innately
Todd and in graphics certainly graphics
the state of the art has been pushed by
gaming requirements and now networking
for vas multiplayer games yeah as well
as mobile yeah I mean if you look what's
what's making money on the App Store you
know it's it's games it's game yeah um
Bria so I see quite a few people here in
this room whom I've taught thank you for
taking my classes thank you for not
sleeping through them when you did I see
some of you who I'm lucky enough to
continue working with like Patrick
Flanagan over there who's raise your
hand Patrick's of people can know you
and I can embarrass the heck out of you
now who's I'm lucky enough to work with
on his PhD so he came through the I&I
program and he's working with me on his
ph.d along with General Motors so thank
you to all of you who've you know made
my life very fulfilling for the time
that I thought here as for what I do
right now as I said until I moved to
Pittsburgh didn't really know much about
sports i came to pittsburgh and fell
very hard in love with football and
hockey um and this is again an example
of what CM you can do to you not the
football part but the fact that you know
you can pursue your own interests and
you can pursue interdisciplinary things
so once i started watching football I
would throw things at the TV when a call
then go the Steelers way and you start
thinking this is a problem this is a
real problem for me at least it's a
genuine problem right and how do you go
about solving that problem and i teach
embedded systems for a living so you
start to think how do you put these two
things together and so immediately the
idea comes you know why don't you put a
chip in the football so you can tell
where the football lands fourth and
inches versus the first time so we went
down that path and started doing exactly
those kinds of projects for the last
three four years and as much fun as it
sounds it's really really really hard
and the reason it's hard is most of the
technologies out there in the networking
industry or the wireless industry for
doing localization which means how do
you know where
something is are within feet range yards
range football is a game of inches
nothing is as more as demanding as that
in terms of you've got to localize the
ball and here's where it gets even more
fun they can be umpteen players on top
of it and the guy at the bottom of the
file is going to nudge it over right and
you've got to be able to make that
decision that the ball actually landed
in the right place and for those of you
watched last year's Super Bowl the NFL
Commissioner actually in his you know
pre-super Bowl press conference said hey
someday we're going to have a chip in
the football I hope that comes from CMU
right and and so we started building
things like that you know we put I mean
we put sensors into anything that moves
and we put it that way we put it into
you know vests of football players to
know whether they've you know they're
ready to go back and play after
concussions we've put it in helmets for
the same reason we've put it in gloves
do you know whether the guy wobbled the
ball again one of those things that I
you know I get really mad about and
throw things at the TV for so you know
put sensors into gloves so we know
whether he's wobbled the ball with a yes
possession of it control put things into
shoes so we can help a punt kick or kick
better because again we also think about
high school players and junior players
right i mean they're a lot of kids want
to go out and become the best punt kick
her out there but they can't afford to
hire the coaches to do it but if they
could actually get the data
independently and know how good they are
they can make that decision and take
that data to the coach right so we've
looked at things like that and then
again following my love for sports more
in the mobility space i used to go to a
lock a lot of hockey games and i always
got cheap nosebleed seats I still get
cheap nosebleed seats and when i'm going
to cheap nosebleed seat i mean all of
you can see how tall I am when I stand
up I'm not so far and there's always a
tall guy in front of me who stands up
and cuts my view of the goal off then
the jumbotron guy decides how I should
see a replay I think these things are
unfair right and again you've got to
decide how you take technology and try
to solve that problem and again we
started thinking how do you solve that
problem will let everyone have their own
personal broadcast let everyone decide
how they should see a replay which angle
they want to watch it let them see the
sweat on the players face if they want
to see it why should only the jumbotron
guys here right and so we started
thinking about that and really the
solution to that can step back from it
is large-scale live mobile streaming
indoors and no company out there has
done it yet were the first to have died
actually piloted it for the Pittsburgh
Penguins a local hockey team and
actually piloted through an entire 70
games of a season and actually proven
that this can work and now this has an
interest from NFL teams and be a teams
it's getting deployed everywhere under
consideration for the Olympics in 2012 I
mean so it's amazing that this little
thing that can come out of what you love
and finding pain points and things you
love and CMU giving you the license to
go off and dream up these things and
students willing to take a shot on you
to go work with you to do this that's
where it can take it thank you very much
priya Marshall yes so I get really
excited hearing that one of the things
that I'm doing with AT&T is I'm with the
antenna solutions team and one of the
issues that we're having and my sole
purpose in life at this moment is to get
AT&T wireless solution and coverage and
capacity into public venues Heinz Field
stadiums convention centers where when
you put a hundred thousand people in
cowboy stadium the wireless network is a
rather interesting to see those
statistics on Monday morning to say the
least and so one of the things that
makes that challenge is this type of
research or things like the iphone when
everybody pulled out their iPhone and
something happens at the game and they
want to send some video they've captured
they want to send some picture that they
taken across the network backcross
internet to a friend that's sitting at
home that creates some real challenges
for us on the mobile networking as these
type of applications become more
prevalent we as a company and as a
provider to increase our customer
experience really have to solve that
problem one of the thing that I find
interesting this is my first time
actually sent a scene since I left and
my senior thesis to talk about this
evolution while i was in iran i was
actually working with him and we were
doing a wireless at the time application
that we were working on was to UM help
technicians if they were going out to do
repairs they couldn't carry binders of
graphics but if they're out in the field
how do we get those graphics to them
remotely and that was in 1996 and so
over time
time it's been a very interesting
phenomena in the telecom industry to
kind of see that evolved when I left on
I though I had done the one for
researching and wireless I actually went
back to AT&T southwestern bell at the
time to do advanced intelligent networks
where we were trying to lock simple
things that we take for granted right
now like caller ID and pull those off of
the switches and put them in central
locations but as you hit the databases
and service how do we get that
transmitted properly across the network
and so over time I I did that and then I
did internet and now i'm back and
wireless trying to help solve this
capacity and coverage issues when you
have lots of people with wireless
devices where this the iphone or
hopefully one day the device that can
give you instant replays replaying every
customer wanted you know a different
angle on those digital dugout kind of
feature so it's been an interesting
ionized definitely been very
instrumental in that we talked about the
business aspects of that and Jim talked
about who can bring the computer
sciences and the engineers and the MBAs
all together and I think we're only
probably half there are still kind of
wonder what our marketing teams thinking
sometimes but it does help me to have
been at iron I to be able to use those
interdisciplinary skills I've done
engineering I managed our internet work
network operations center for about 18
months and that's always interesting and
whether you're talking you know millions
of dsl customers or you have the bank of
america traffic going across the network
and they want it up every time someone
wants to hit the server right and so
it's been a very good experience and i
can't say nothing and for a seaman
Marvin Dina and the people at ion I that
just kind of helped me launch my career
and whether I was trying to draw upon
technical skills or business skills I've
managed half a billion dollar on
portfolios for AT&T so it's been a good
experience thank you
see thanks Myron yeah thanks Marsh I was
great experience and I was really very
happy seeing you today after 15 years
almost yeah just to build on that little
bit it was a project where student did
wireless transmission of audio and video
accessing legacy data or databases for
now it's called Bombardier at that time
or a trans which was subsidiary of
daimler-benz here in Pittsburgh
manufacturing as you probably know
they're the largest manufacturers of
those Airport trains and some other high
speed trains in North America at that
time they were subsidiary they settled
I'm events and how visionary that
project was in nineteen ninety five and
six perhaps the best demonstration is
that I was invited to give a talk about
that project in 2003 at the World
Congress on high-speed trains and euro
train setting levels the name of the
event in Madrid Spain which was opened
by king of Spain so it was seven years
later a couple of the other projects
that happened at that time and then I
students took place and they are pretty
visible the auto publications by then
our augmented reality projects for Weber
computer and augmented reality projects
for buying an electric boat for Boeing
clearly it was applied airplane
maintenance manufacturing for electric
boat nuclear submarines meant as a
manufacturing at that time augmented
reality was those who are probably first
or among the first projects in augmented
reality and larval computing total very
what augmented reality me right so that
meant not only overlaying parts of the
aircraft skin or or construction on the
unhealthy spray but also doing
registration so that depending on where
person views which part of the plane
wearable system brings up appropriate
schematics and imaging just depending
another location a location of
why are you viewing the plane was a thin
chucking was within one millimeter
accuracy at that time so system
automatically from web more computer on
your belt brings up schematics images
drawings information that you need to
repair or construct the airplane or to
maintain airplane now you can imagine at
the Boeing site near Seattle at that
time if engineer needs needs manuals
they might be taken by somebody else or
even if you pick it up at Sandra yards
away from you you need to find drawing
or schematics that you need now you can
calculate how much time you need for
that so it still sounds visionary
nowadays but in 96 about this product is
going SATA 292 so 19 for we had system
in place that he demonstrated at Boeing
with these capabilities the project was
funded by NSF and DARPA and boink was
co-sponsored similarly for for electric
board for nuclear submarines now just
applied for submarines if submarine has
at least at that time 400 different
where loves and now you can imagine how
to manage their construction and and
integration with with the main bodies
again we built Weber computer wireless
communication capabilities in pretty
tough environment because submarines
spent a lot of their time as you know
under the water and and another very
interesting very very complex project
let me run at that time now I believe
just going for forward one of the first
cell phones or context where mobile
phones called sensei was also done at
CMU in 2002 with participation of honor
students and the journal conference
publications both at is still visionary
what was done they are the cell phone
was able to understand for example that
you are at a conference sitting
discussing engaged in communication so
nobody can interrupt you we are phone or
sure
on the dollar and trying to grab your
attention if somebody calls you the cell
phone was able to even understand at
that time level of your engagement and
as the person to call second time in
three minutes or 15 minutes in
conjunction with GM project that system
was also able to shut your position and
if you are meeting with me coming from
Israel downtown in 10 minutes and you
know you have traffic and all other
conditions on the road the system was
able again to understand if you can't
make it if you're nervous in the game
put any incoming voice phone call in to
the voice mail queue so those
capabilities we had in 2002 and Prince
Andrew of Great Britain came to visit
Pittsburgh we came for a conference in
2003 the only demonstration he wanted to
see the demonstration of the sensei here
in Pittsburgh then recently recently we
have a couple of the visionary project
and let me just mention one of them
which are somehow shaping i believe the
agenda of the mobile computing in the
next ten years at least we are putting
physiological sensors on HS band
including EKG respiration rate heartbeat
rate of course accelerometer which is no
theological sensors i think i mentioned
all of them that can track your vital
signs in provided an indication about
your stress level but then that
indication goes on to your mobile phone
because we are now running on androids a
support of the machines library SVM
library which was pretty much on
thinkable excuse me couple of years ago
and on cell phone calculating the your
stress level and of course indication
with appropriate advice or warming what
you should do too
to minimize or reduces the stress level
and that's one of the I believe
patristic application with a cell phones
anyhow in medical applications and this
is just one example where they can
nicely indicate your your stress level
again I have I&I students engage on that
and I'm glad to say that then I students
over all these many years have
contributed a lot to shaping history and
I believe future also mobile computing
he more than a few projects that seem
has been involved with I remember one
where he was developing one of the first
probe handheld computers that ran a full
computer operating system and a group of
students from the eye and I took that
and wrote the first software that turned
that handheld computer into a voice
terminal using voice over Internet
Protocol so today if you are running
skype on your iPhone we were doing the
first predecessors of that 10 years ago
thanks Mary another exciting pointed at
this point I want to throw it open to
questions from the audience do you have
questions about the directions that I
and I about the sorts of things that
students do your own experiences that
you want to share
no one
and Furies
subsets that telling me
here so what do you think
paradigm or
an excellent question Jesse you want to
start without I'm gonna ask I'm this
Emma's dad everybody take a credit bad
not not mean to pick on you Jesse yeah
no I think I think one of the things
that is certainly happening in the game
industry is the is connectedness already
people have been sort of surprised and
delighted by some of the things that
have been happening in terms of gaming
and connectedness the whole concept of
Facebook gaming really took took the
world a little bit by surprise I think
this past year and the part that people
seem to like about it so Wells it's
built off of your existing social
network so that it just removes barriers
between you and your friends because
that's one of the things that games are
certainly for and I think we're going to
see more and more of this I think will
become a normal thing very soon for you
to boot up your game console and
immediately just be connected with all
the people you've already made friends
with on Facebook or Twitter just or
whatever is going to be the dominant
social network and I'll I'll step out
and say five years from now i believe
Facebook will still be the dominant
social network I'll just there I'll be
back here in five years and you can all
say look how wrong you were but I don't
I don't think I'm wrong about that so
certainly the issues of connectedness
and a lot of that connect and this is
going to come through through mobile
technologies and specifically I think a
lot of its going to start to come
through disposable technologies we're
going to end up in situations very soon
where we're going to have wireless
connectivity in things that you know we
didn't spend three hundred dollars on
but rather on things that we spent
twenty dollars on or ten dollars on or
five dollars on because we because
Moore's Law is still in effect these
things are still are getting cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper and so it's going to
become very normal for everything in our
lives to kind of have some level of
connectivity and one of the things we're
already seeing in terms of gaming is
weird unexpected connections between
these virtual economies which are very
powerful psychological motivators for
people
and actual economies in the real world a
concrete example that would be Microsoft
has been trying to get people to use
their Bing search engine and one of the
things that they recently did was they
cut a deal with Zynga where they said if
you become a fan of the Bing search
engine will give you three farm cash so
it's virtual money they're going to give
you in the farmville game and this drove
significant traffic to the Bing search
engine more so than any of their other
advertising campaigns more so than their
television ads or anything else because
it was a situation where people were
right there able to use the product and
I think we're going to see a lot more
overlap once the grocery stores start to
wise up about how valuable the data they
have is and they're going to start to
realize how they can connect that to
virtual economies and things so I think
one of the things we're going to see in
the gaming world is gaming coming out of
its normal places in kind of weaving
itself through all the parts of our
lives great um so I think as an
extension of some of the things that
I've said and also some of the things
that you've heard on the panel you've
seen over the last maybe three four
years this thing called cloud computing
and data centers take off but if you
look at it on mobile phones mobile
phones are growing larger there should
be a day when you know you can
essentially create a virtual data center
of all the phones you and your friends
have access to that would be really cool
if in fact all of your data all the bits
in your life was stored on some mobile
device and obviously that you know you
need those are the high bandwidth you
know multimedia intensive applications
some going back to my sports thing again
right so 11 concrete way then that you
could exploit that is think about the
guy who's right up there next to the
glass right he can see you know players
face smash up against the glass better
than anybody else he can see that fight
better than anybody else there's no
camera down there right but if you could
co-opt the phone of the guy who's
sitting right there who has that premium
see that you can never get your hands on
at least I can never get my hands on
right and if you could get him
film that moment and he could give you
the rights to that for that instant of
time so you felt you were in issues now
you've got something cool but you can't
really do that today because you don't
have the network fabric to support that
kind of high intensive mean high
bandwidth intensive application you can
do some things like mobile streaming
video indoors we've done it for
thousands of people but we can't yet do
that we can't yet create a mobile data
center just out of phones going back
again to the example and Haiti right if
you could just take the phones of all
the people there and create a virtual
data center that allowed them to share
information on the fly creating a data
center essentially on the fly creating a
mobile cloud computing environment that
would be cool that's something we're
working on already at CMU across our
campus testbed we've deployed a number
of phones that we're hoping will turn
into one of those kinds of mobile cloud
computing centers that we will then
actually try to deploy in a real life
stadium and we want to see what the
effects of that would be but again I
think that's a that's a huge trend I
don't know what to follow with that
because I actually was thinking about
the cloud computing hadn't quite gone to
the face against the glass but um this
is mu so they go there before you do
right so I I definitely think that
wireless capacity everybody's putting a
chip in everything and the more we do
that and it's really about enhancing our
lives and for some of those for some of
us it's an enhancement some of us is
people can find us where we are and
we're not sure that's enhancing it right
but how do you get people what they need
whatever they are whether you're talking
mobile cloud computing or getting
information to customers I think it's
it's a speed how do you build an
infrastructure how do you build the
software how do you build the
applications that are going to enable
and so sex that you have open interfaces
because that's one of the challenges
that we have in a competitive I
met you you want both open but you still
want your competitive edge right so how
do you leverage that for the customers
yet still make it a profitable business
model and so this notion of computing
from a telecommunication perspective and
cloud computing in particular it is very
attractive for at least the person that
gets there first into a best for
everybody else is going to be a
challenge well let me ask you one
question increasingly we're seeing
people talk about devices other than
phones that are going to be enabled for
cellular the coke machine that
automatically calls the distributor and
says I'm empty or the automobile that
calls GM and says this airbags just
deploy that's call call the emergency
people what's happening with device
based cellular if we will and where do
you see happening with that from a
emerging devices it's what we refer to
those at AT&T and you're talking your
coke machines or even if you're talking
to stadium where the person I really
don't want to move to the order the hot
dog in the coke how can i enable them to
be able to have a device that says I'm
NC 155 role whatever I won't hide out
hope nachos hold jalapenos right and
that shows up mm-hm and there's a lot of
activity around that around the world a
10-10 particular are partnering with a
lot of devices we're having forms and
consortium with developers to really
enable the applications for that and so
I think you know where that gold is
really kind of limitless as you start to
talk about the technology and so we want
the partnership with the device folks
but it's really our network that we're
trying to harness and how do we set the
network up to baby where we're talking
our mobile network IP backbone the cloud
computing and this is a world wide
network and worldwide issue that we're
trying to solve so the device the
emerging device space is pretty
and we're starting to see partnership
with a tomtom and other providers I'm in
that arena but it won't be a phone issue
i mean we love the phone we love the
iphone me and there but there there will
be another iphone they'll build another
application it may not even be a phone
in whatever the super gadget may be so
there are definitely some device
activity happening and it's one of those
how far can you push it and how do you
build the right business partnerships to
make that work because it you know I
don't envision that eight NT themselves
would be there will be an apple
partnership ass it's full partnership or
tomtom partnership and leveraging
building partnerships so that you
leverage what people do best and
hopefully we can talk to some folks at
carnegie about some of the cool research
that's going on and how do we start now
to build a network so that as that path
develops we ensure that we're on the
right track I mean we're leveraging
starting to try out some 4G technology
that hopefully is going to give us the
capacity to be able to handle these
devices everywhere but there's a lot of
work to be done in that arena see true
but all of you have witnessed situation
that when you are on the move you need
much more help than they are in the
office anywhere from your work
activities if they are outside when you
are curious when you're visiting
different places there that's much more
unstructured environment than your
regular office space now there's one of
the reasons why even today you don't
leave your home without cell phone you
try to have it with you all the time but
I would just enjoy your attention to an
application or problem in the future
that would mean a lot as a new
application for the cell phones one of
the breakthrough applications would be
determining person of user
10th I think all ingredients that are
needed for that like sensory support
machine learning support etc are present
and that can be done in X and we are
also working on that in the next few
years now you can imagine if your cell
phone can understand what you'll need
next and proactively bring that
information to you and you you have it
in time and you need it I think that
would be a great new capability to
expect such a help from the cell phone
and I expect that we will have it here
in HCM you in the next couple of years
yes come
hmm well common refers to a project that
we did beginning in 1992 actually before
the web even existed we envisioned that
people might want to download
information across the internet and that
they'd have to be some way to pay for it
in order to finance people making it
available and we started developing
billing systems that could allow you to
buy journal articles at ten cents a page
and you can't use a credit card for
something that costs ten cents because
the credit card companies have a minimum
charge of a quarter so we developed
something we called the internet billing
server was re-engineered by the next
class and re-engineered for the web the
1994 and eventually became a major
research project that we license to
cyber cash corporation interestingly
enough the notion of micro payments or
being able to build for something for
the billing charges fractions of a penny
so you can sell something for a dime has
not taken off in society at large
they're talking about they well that's
the smallest increment typically is the
99 cents for an itune Oh in the United
States mm-hmm what the heck's a problem
with the United States Asia and Europe
have the micro payments all over the
place and I don't frankly understand
this I'm hoping someone in this room can
answer this question for me I mean
because in like I mean again I've got my
head in the gaming space and gaming
space in in Asia and Europe is
completely dominated by micro payments
it's starting to be any any online
gaming is happening and a big part of
that is people do they do the building
to their cell phone you want to build
ten cents to your cell phone snap no
problem why is it a big problem in the
United States is completely beyond me
no no really yeah it's an interesting
question we we ultimately did some
economics research to try and understand
why why this wasn't taking off in the
information space and concluded that
there were strong reasons why
information goods wouldn't be marketed
that way that most of the people he
wanted to sell to one of a lot of
information for them it was much better
to solve a subscription for twenty or
fifty dollars a month and then you don't
have to have micro payments and the
advertising industry on the web has been
so lucrative that a lot of people find
that they can support their websites
without any payments just through
advertising so between the no payment
advertising supported and the
subscription model the micro payments
model has not proven to have a
significantly large niche in the US well
but I don't understand why why we don't
have the payments between cell phones
like you do elsewhere well ticket it's
like I mean for example like that by far
the dominant the dominant Facebook game
accompanied is Inga everything for them
is as a micro payment system which
fortunately has made somewhat easier on
their system in Europe big point is
Germany's you know a company doing this
they have and they're having a much
easier time but big point is having a
hard time coming to the US because the
the cell phone companies here refused to
support micro pendants and I just I
don't understand it it's like they were
allergic to money or something and I
have not yet found anyone who
understands an explanation of why Europe
and Asia have this down but we don't
have here we have to do with different
banking rules so it would be an
interesting question yeah take a look at
I don't know I don't know if it's a
legal thing or a culture thing it's it's
a mystery to me
so but you were asking what the payment
protocol will be and the answer is I
don't know but maybe it'll come out of
Europe and now that I look out of I mi
athens instead of my and I Pittsburgh I
I don't know but that may be the next
question we should be looking at my
stuff we talked about midnight
books experienced at their ages
yes absolutely absolutely the literature
says to the taste teenager spends
several hours a day being connected
whether it's Facebook or their phones or
instant messaging or whatever vastly
larger than any previous generation and
it's got to change the way they think
about interacting and it's a very
different connecting model when you
start looking at that generation right
so what I think I had to get a job
before I got a cell phone but they don't
rate but we have on average that like 10
to 12 sent 4,000 text messages a month
four thousand can you afford and I'm
just nervous for the day they start
sending video that way that's going to
drive the network bananas right oh you
got into it don't be then what are you
worried about I'm enjoying but there's a
cost to doing it and you got to get
ahead of that curve right so hopefully I
don't do it for 4g 4g shows up we will
see so sorry at that kind of volume
right it's a very different model in the
access that the information that they
have access to also drives different
behavior and they're not even when like
you know we have people that were
sitting in front of laptops or you know
in front of their computer doing work
they're doing this gaming and from
handheld devices and so it's going to be
a very different connection model that
from a from a teaching perspective they
wanted I think need to understand the
technology there really are no limits to
where they're going to go we just got to
figure out now how to build the
infrastructure to enable them to do what
they're going to be asking to do 10
years from now it's a new culture and
all that social networking and use of
technology is clearly changing their
life as I said earlier cell phones are
wearable computers there are computers
nowadays and the way youngsters interact
with them and use them for several hours
a day it's clearly a new new new quality
in their life assuming they are using
that
for pasta purposes now they're also some
more intelligent applications that can
be built and used by them anywhere from
you know the our capabilities now that
they can have on their cell for what
what are cool places in peaceful tonight
for their age still doesn't exist
hopefully that will also be you know in
existence in here or two from now so
there are some more intelligent
applications that they can be the users
or can contribute and I hope to see more
of that pretty soon so I want to add one
more thing there so I think there's
always a little bit of attention at
least for me in teaching as technology
advances because sometimes the tools are
made so much easier you forget how it
works underneath and you always face
that in teaching because you always want
them to learn the latest and greatest
but they're never going to learn the
underpinnings of something because it
has been made transparent right and so
for me that's always something the
balance you teach them how to use this
but at the same time open up the hood
and say this is how it used to be 30
years ago and this is the evolution
because if you don't know that she can't
be informed about where to go 20 years
from now we all know electricity comes
out of outlets in the wall and not much
about what's behind it well we've used
up our our I'm afraid and I want to
thank our panel very much for I think
what has been a very stimulating session
and thank our audience for very good
questions
you